and Dr Gay does calling for the genocide
of Jews violate Harvard's rules of
bullying and harassment yes or no it can
be depending on the context what's the
context targeted as an individual
targeted as at an individual it's
targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals I will ask you one more time
does calling for the genocide of Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no again it depends on
the context not depend on the context
the answer is yes and this is why you
should resign these are unacceptable
answers across the board thankfully
everyone with their head on straight and
there still are a couple people uh are
calling this out for the abject lunacy
that it is here's Elon Musk who know is
not an anti-semite let me help them out
here calling for the genocide death of
anyone obviously constitutes harassment